les gens qui étaient dans cet internat
m'appelait poubelles d'une poubelle
les profs aussi l'appeler comme ça le
vendredi soir il le jetait toutes les
peaux toutes leurs poubelles dans mon
box
[Musique]
bon
j'étais changer de collège à un moment
donné donc dans cette ville tor seconde
droit en seconde je me suis retrouvé
dans le privé donc chez les curés en
vendée dans un internat et j'ai pas
envie d'y être
alors
pour peut-être pas pourquoi mais je me
lavais plus oui je sentais fort sentait
toutes sortes de choses
le souci son urine et c'est donc à tel
point que même mais mes collègues faire
mes collègues mais les gens qui étaient
dans cet internat m'appelait poubelle
nous tous devenus poubelle les profs
aussi l'appeler comme ça donc je j'avais
choisi finalement c'était même un choix
personnel d'être le bouc émissaire de
de ce dortoir le vendredi soir je t'ai
toutes les peaux toutes leurs poubelles
dans mon box alors j'allais chercher
dans les déchets tout ça d'ailleurs je
trouvais des merveilles vraiment et je
dis que c'est presque un choix parce que
je prenais quand même aussi plaisir au
fait d'être exclu je voulais pas rester
salle je voulais me sentais bien que
c'est une voie sans issue
alors au bout de cette année là
j'ai demandé à mes parents de me changer
d'école se retrouver dans le public est
là tout s'est décanté pour moi j'ai fait
des très bonnes rencontres même si j'ai
commencé à boire et fumer mais enfin bon
ça faisait partie aussi de ce processus
et donc je me retrouvais donc dans le
public avec des gens plus ouverts
du coup je retourne à sion sous la
douche se sentait bon le savons et
shampoings et cette année là je
commençais à tout ce que je fais
aujourd'hui c'est à dire dessinée
d'abord
mais
amis mes profs dans le journal du
collège je dessinais beaucoup j'ai
commencé cette année là aussi faire des
chansons donc tout s'est décanté après
cette épreuve finalement que kim avait
été imposée que je m'étais imposé aussi
moi même il a vraiment fallu que je sois
au fond de la piscine pour pouvoir
remonter